الخلاف حول استقبال سفينه اوشن فايكنج
للمهاجرين عن غير الشرعيين نسخه مستحدثه
من توترات حصلت قبل اربع سنوات بين كل من
فرنسا وايطاليا لكن النهج المتشدد لرئيسه
الوزراء الايطاليه الجديده جورجيا ميلوني
زهدها حده او زادها حده ففي اول خلاف
عالمي منذ تسليمها السلطه انتقدت ميلون رد
فعل فرنسا الذي وصفته بالعدواني وغير
المبرر رفضه مزاعم فرنسيه بان حكومتها
تتهرب من مسؤولياتها لنقل المهاجرين عبر
البحر الاسود
الرد الايطالي جاء بعد اتهامات من
الخارجيه الفرنسيه واجهتها لروما بالاخلال
بالالتزامات الاوروبيه وعدم احترام
القانونين الدولي والبحري وهددتها بمواجهه
العواقب من جهتها استنكرت سلطات روما
التهديدات الفرنسيه المباشره لها مبديه
مخاوفها من ان تشمل الاجراءات الانتقاميه
تقييد وصولها لاموال الاتحاد الاوروبي
المخصصه للتعافي من كورونا وكانت ايطاليا
رفضت استقبال سفينه تديرها منظمه خيريه
تحمل نحو 230 مهاجرا انقاذهم في البحر ثم
شكرت لاحقا فرنسا التي وافقت على استقبال
السفينه في ميناء
[موسيقى]